I'm your guest bailiff Tiffany Haddish
and now here's your Judge the Honorable
justice Amen Jesus ha hello time to play
good judge hi judge which one will I be
the plaintiff wins the defendants a car
but never got it back the defendant says
the car had expired tags and was
impounded Latasha Litella I mean this is
not a good idea to put a high judge in
front of this case because just keeping
your names and parts gonna be quite
difficult but I'm gonna give it my best
l'Italia you brought us here what's your
complaint
I'll let Latasha use my vehicle which
was Alexis and I specifically told them
that the tags without dating and there
was ticket on the car and within two
weeks the car was gone because they live
by police station and they parked the
car on the street like that seems like a
very safe place to park no that's not a
viable market so far with no tag oh so
there are yes and the agreement was that
$2,700 that I paid for my vehicle will
get paid back to me that kelly blue book
or latoya blue book yeah probably a real
book that's Bluto
[Music]